So when you do this you could then come up with a UML diagram that organizes
the important nouns related to the electronics into a, into a diagram.
In this case there's main classes having to do with the coffee maker which
as you indicated, then has parts corresponding to the graphical user interface.
That would be the buttons and the, the lights to the the part
having to do with the, the boiler which includes a sensor and
a heater and the warming plate which also includes a sensor and
a heater. And then you might get excited by the fact you have two heaters and
have an abstract class for heater and the same thing for
sensor and come up with a diagram that looks something like this.